what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so I was sitting here thinking I was
like yeah we finally get to cover the
story where the son of Hulk's car fights
Wolverine and the son of Wolverine and
Jed or not it's gonna be amazing and
then I started getting into it now I was
like wait a minute now now wait a minute
we missed something we missed that right
turn at Albuquerque I think it's how a
good as we zigged when we should have
zagged and as I was going through I was
like what did I miss
because I was trying to figure out what
I missed because there was a story that
correlated there was a story that linked
the first volume of Skaar son of Hulk to
basically the the region where I guess
the the reintroduction of the Incredible
Hulk series that featured Bruce Banner
and then I realized we never covered the
story where Skaar fought his dad we
never cover the story where Skaar fought
Hulk and so we're gonna we're gonna
cover that here we're gonna pick up with
this now if somebody keep in mind for a
lot of you guys who are just now joining
in with my run on the Incredible Hulk in
the playlist down in the description I
have it done in chronological order and
so this story actually comes before the
last video where spider-man fights Red
Hulk chronologically it comes before
that so in the playlist it'll be before
that but if you guys would find yourself
overwhelmed if you find yourself a bit
confused by what's going on maybe a
little bit lost and the whole run of
everything that's happening that
playlist will give you all the videos in
chronological order so you can get
caught up and he could make sure that
you know you're aware of what's going on
as we progress through these videos
having said that at the end of the first
run of scar set of Hulk it basically saw
him being teleported to the planet Earth
and we didn't really know exactly what
had happened there all we knew was that
the Incredible Hulk seemed to become
aware of his sense presence at the same
time this actually takes place during
the events of Dark Reign now for those
of you guys who don't know Dark Reign
was the post Secret Invasion slash Civil
War event and essentially saw Tony Stark
being removed as director of shield and
replaced with Norman Osborn now the
reason for this was because of the fact
that Secret Invasion basically
established that these Scrolls had taken
over a huge majority of Earth and
because of the fact that Tony Stark and
shield were not aware of this it was a
demonstration at least as far as the
government
the Tony Stark was effectively inept as
the leader of shield and so they cast
him out Norman Osborn kind of wiggled
his way in and then of course he
launched hammer and basically turned
shield into this dictatorial group that
is to say he was basically using the law
to effectively put himself in absolute
power now the funny thing about this was
that he had his own team he had like
Dark Avengers he had a the dark x-men
and there's a whole different series of
stories based on that because Dark Reign
unlike traditional crossovers doesn't
have a main line of stories itself so
much as it has a series of just small
stories that make up the greater whole
if that makes any sense but what this
did is it gave us a chance to see
different characters like hate Wayne's
World as well as the return of the
warbound now the warbound didn't just
vanish off the face of the earth right I
mean after world war hulk we had an
event called after smash which showed
different things i don't think it was a
really important thing but what it did
give us is kate Waynesboro who basically
absorbed the powers of heroine and what
had happened was she'd been caught up in
a campaign involving a villain named the
leader but the idea was a hero had
effectively been killed and his ability
to use the old power which is to say to
basically manipulate the tectonic plates
of any given planet that he's on was
passed on to kate Waynesboro
and it was a chance to take her
character who had been a background
character in The Incredible Hulk mythos
as part of shield and so on and so forth
and elevate her to the forefront but
with the arrival of Skaar being here the
idea was to basically I guess on behalf
of Norman Osborn was to effectively go
through and try to find out Skaar learn
more about him you know learn what he's
about try to find a way at the very
least take a member and rally him to his
cause just because of the fact that
Norman Osborn recognized that if there
was an equivalent of the Incredible Hulk
fighting on his side it would make him
absolutely powerful in terms of his
ability to quash threat stuff and things
like that but much like Bruce Banner
Skaar kind of has this idea of being
left alone to a degree but we're
actually gonna learn he's really a man
on a mission here but what this does is
it picks up with him you know speaking
with a couple of kids now these kids
aren't wildly important so far and that
they basically show us how it is that
Skaar views the world and what I mean
here is that these kids are kind of
talking with them you know they're
they're teasing him a little bit but
there seems to be here some respect for
them not only that it seems that you
know Skaar is gonna go about killing
people or the very least trying to
achieve a goal from there it actually
jumps back a bit and it kind of gives us
you know caught up on its history in the
sense that he had basically been given
the opportunity to save his people when
it was deemed the Galactus was going to
consume Sekar and
as vengeance in his hatred as well as as
hubris he believed he could take on
Galactus using the old power he was
proven to be wrong and the result was
that he was effectively cast out by the
spiritual essence of his mother and sent
to earth and the result of this is that
once he arrives when he's when he's
talking to these kids of course one of
them basically falls off the cliff now
the young girl runs off she runs in a
cop she tells the cops hey look I need
help but what this is doing is it's
basically creating a scenario whereby
scar cannot trust humanity because
remember when he first got here he was a
guy who was immersed in hatred he was a
guy who was immersed in rage but it
wasn't like he viewed humanity as
intrinsically distrustful it wasn't like
humanity was inherently bad instead it
was literally him just kind of learning
about humans as he encountered them the
problem with this as one of his first
encounters is a misunderstanding where
he had tried to save the boy and the boy
had effectively suffered some major
injuries instead the police believe that
scar was the reason why this kid almost
died and so they immediately take him
into custody because of this scar
basically developed a hatred for
humanity and in doing so turns on these
cops now of course this is when the
Incredible Hulk first becomes aware of
his existence becomes aware the fact
that he's there not only that the
rampage that scar is going on is being
followed by the warbound being led by
Kate Warrensburg and so once they
finally get there kate says hey look I
know I'm not necessarily of Sekar but I
do have the old power by way of hero am
I understand what it is you're going
through because remember when a person
has the old power they effectively have
the legacy of the entire race I mean
it's not like you simply just absorb the
abilities to manipulate tectonic plates
you absorb everything that is the
history of the shadow culture so because
of that you basically know everything
about them you feel what they feel
you've seen what they've seen and you've
seen the history of Sekar through your
own eyes and your own experiences and so
for Kate Waynesboro her having the old
power allows her to understand the
hatred that scar has right now but to
also understand where he's coming from
in terms of his own experiences now from
here she tries to appeal to him to
basically say hey look we've seen where
you're coming from
we are the warbound we were the friends
of the Incredible Hulk were your friends
you know ally yourself with us and we
can show you the way now initially it
seems like scars who want to side with
them but was really funny here is once
they basically extend this Olive ranch
once warg sits down and says hey I will
help you find your father I will help
you find yourself the scar says I'm not
in this to try to find my dad like I'm
not in this
try to you know mend the rift between
the two of us I'm in this because I want
to find him and I want to kill him and
this is when the Incredible Hulk shows
up now to be honest with you guys this
is this is an thing if there
ever was one this is one of the one of
the most amazing things because we sit
down right and we look at scar and scar
is just like unbridled force I mean he's
just Rage personified that's really what
he is he's just he's your angsty
teenager angry at the world you know the
world didn't give him what he wanted one
day and so he's going to take it out on
everybody everybody's gonna feel his
wrath that's basically what he is you
know he's a teenager you say okay get
over yourself
you'll be fine move on the Sun will rise
tomorrow The Incredible Hulk is seasoned
I mean he's a seasoned guy he's had his
ups and downs he's fought gods he's
fought mortals he's been the good guy
he's been the bad guy world breaker Hulk
is the epitome of his absolute strength
and what Skaar is actually looking for
is not just a fight but his father not
just a fight the Incredible Hulk but to
fight world breaker whole now the reason
why he wants to fight that version of
the Hulk is because as he tells a banner
himself growing up that's all he ever
heard from anybody who knew who the Hulk
was you know even after the Incredible
Hulk had basically taken off from Sekar
after the crown city was destroyed after
his wife was killed and he believed his
son had died the rumors still spread
across a planet of you know the the
green scarf the sack arson this
unbridled force in the history of the
car that literally cast off the Red King
saved everybody on the planet and was
virtually unchallenged by anyone no one
could stand against the Incredible Hulk
these are the stories that scar heard
and so what happened is that over the
course of his experiences and while he's
trying to fight the Incredible Hulk here
he's getting his ass whooped in no
uncertain terms and this is this is
exactly how it happened this is exactly
how it needed to unfold because scars
cool I love the character a scarf scarf
and mmm were bad bad boy we are of a
like mind Internet brofist because I'm a
PewDiePie fan by the way but Internet
fist bump I'd like the character of scar
I love him for what he is because he's
so cool but he has nothing on the
Incredible Hulk I'm sorry I'm sorry I
gotta go old-school here when it comes
to e credible Hulk Papa Bear reign
supreme like he knows it he you don't
you don't mess with the Hulk man and so
the result of this is that once he's
easily able to take his son out you know
once he's able to pummel him in the
Stream you know scar keeps coming back
but something else I'd also like you to
notice here is that the incredible
honker doesn't seem to know who the
warbound are now the reason for this is
because this is an instance of two
different types of incredible hooks when
it came to whoa breaker Hulk that was in
and of itself a singular transformation
I mean that was the equivalent of the
Incredible Hulk going super saiyan for
lack of a better word you know that
that's associate what that was it was
him taking on a whole new state of being
you know he had the intelligence or not
really the intelligence a banner but he
had the wherewithal of a conscious being
he wasn't just savage and running amuck
but he had strength that it was hitherto
unseen when it came to any version of
the Incredible Hulk
but this is savage Hulk in his true form
it's the simple minded easily confused
but wildly powerful Incredible Hulk the
funny thing about this is that you know
when he says why do you want to fight me
when he asks car why do you want to go
against Reese car says because you know
all I ever heard was that you were a
hero for the question I have is why
would a hero let his son die why would a
hero let his people suffer at the hands
of Axman bone and his you know his
barbarous forces as they were trying to
fill the power vacuum of Sekar and why
would he let the world die the funny
thing about this is that the Hulk
responds by basically saying I have no
idea what you're talking about I don't
know anything about the car I have no
clue what is it you're saying and this
is when the warbound began to realize
that their two distinctly different
beings because keep in mind this is
something to keep in mind guys the
warbound never saw savage hulk they
never saw that version of him from the
time that he first showed up on on
Sicard
all the way up until the time that he
left he was effectively world breaker
Hulk he was the Hulk that showed up in
World War Hulk that iteration um he was
intelligent but he was wildly powerful
he was determined and the reason for
that was because he was just built with
anger at the fact but he was betrayed by
the Illuminati that was a singular goal
was to come back to earth and kill the
Illuminati for casting him out it was
only after kyer died and you know his
family was effectively destroyed that he
showed up and officially went into this
kind of world break or hold form that
was wildly powerful but the warbound
had
never seen savage Hulk and so for them
to suddenly come across this version
that's not very bright but is incredibly
strong that is kind of like what in the
heck because as far as they're concerned
is like the Hawke's loss is mine they
have no idea what's going on they're
like why don't you remember who we are
we literally fought in the gladiatorial
games and he's like I don't remember
what you're talking about they're like
okay well we came to earth and we
basically laid waste to the entirety of
the superhero community the x-men the
Avengers the Fantastic Four like Doctor
Strange we took them all out and he's
like nope still have no idea what you're
talking about you know and he's just
like Hulk is Hulk I don't know what
you're talking about but Hulk is hooked
and so for him for first savage hole
it's mind games
it's them trying to screw with his head
and so because of this once he looks
into his son's eyes that's when it
starts to snap back now the cool thing
about this bit of writing is that it
draws on the history of The Incredible
Hulk when it comes to his multiple
personalities because you know the great
hawk originally was introduced as like a
printing error you know as the fact they
just couldn't keep it going so they
eventually made him green that was just
the explanation well you know we just
can't keep it going so we're making a
green instead it wasn't until years
later that the green Hulk was his own
persona you know we have Joe fix that
hole his gray Hulk we have professor
Hulk we have all these different
versions of the Incredible Hulk
what's happening in this story is
they're basically tapping in and they're
saying that when Bruce Banner
I guess when the Incredible Hulk looked
in the eyes of his son he saw Kyra he
remembered her for a fraction of a
second but then suddenly those memories
get shut out now whether is because
they're too painful whether is because
that personality is trying to surface
and the sound of hoping it back that's
something that's never really explained
here but what we're basically told is
that world breaker Hulk is a different
iteration of the whole it's not the same
as as savage hope the kind that were
traditionally used to seeing so because
of that you know initially simply just
tries to cast off scar and basically say
go away I don't want to have anything to
do with you but scar is like no no no I
came here for a fight and a fight is
what I'm gonna get he tells The
Incredible Hulk he's like either you can
put up and we can fight or you can walk
away but one way or the other man you
are taking this ass-whooping and so
because of that you know with the with
the conflict that they have going on
what's ironic is that they're right next
to a nuclear power plant and so when
you're dealing with force of this
magnitude weird when you're dealing with
the Incredible Hulk who's powerful
enough to punch the ground and create
earthquakes the most logical scenario
happens here in a sense that they
basically just disrupt this nuclear
power plant and they begin the process
of sending it in to melt
now we're the warbound and The
Incredible Hulk step in and try to save
this power plant initially they're not
really successful in doing that but with
Skaar he has the old power and this is
basically Marvel saying the old power
works regardless of what planet you're
on sure the old power originates with
Sekar but it's basically just the
ability to manipulate tectonic plates
and if a planet exists it has tectonic
plates meaning as long as you're
standing on the ground you can
manipulate the tectonic plates of that
planet and achieve virtually any goal
and that's exactly what what Skaar does
he basically uses his old power to
effectively seal off this nuclear power
plant and basically save the lives of
the people who were there you know keep
the whole thing from from melting down
and so from here you know of course we
have Kate Waynesboro who has a really
funny question she says if you're able
to use the old power and you can
manipulate the very structure of the
earth itself you could crack it in half
if you wanted to which kind of makes
them the equivalent of an omega-level
mutant then why do you use a sori so
this is easy it's more fun and then he
plunges the sword into the chest of the
incredible by how awesome is that now
the funny thing about this is that this
is not gonna kill the Incredible Hulk
not by a long shot and Skaar knows this
Skaar knows it's not going to kill the
Hulk all he says here is you are not the
Hulk that I've been told about you're
not this world breaker Hulk this
champion that's absolute power of
physical strength this being whose
strength is virtually unrivaled with the
exception of those who are cosmic
entities and I guess the century you
know he says you are a shadow of your
former self
so come find me when you become world
breaker Hulk again until then leave me
alone like I don't want to have anything
to do with this because you're literally
just a weak and pathetic man now in
truth if this fight had gone on long
enough
Savage Hawk would have killed Skaar I
mean it's just the way this there's
there's no discussion to be had there
like Skaar would have been obliterated
by Savage Hulk because Hulk would just
keep getting stronger and stronger and
stronger Skaar does not have that
ability Skaar does not have infinite
strength The Incredible Hulk does and so
ultimately it would just lead to you
know Skaar being killed either that or
Skaar where somebody just ripped the
planet in half and kill himself and Hulk
at the same time you know kind of look
at it like a no-win situation to say
well fine if I can't win then everyone's
gonna lose and literally just just kill
everybody but that pretty much wraps
things up because what this does is this
wraps back around I guess it kind of
moves forward into the video that we
talked about yesterday with Red Hulk vs.
spider-man and then it allows us to pick
back up with Skaar going against the son
of Wolverine and Wolverine him so
and juggernaut all the while more or
less being tutored by Bruce Banner who
of course has been devoured at this
point again if you guys were a little
fuzzy on that make sure you check lay
list down in the description that
lettuce will get you caught up on where
we're at everything from Planet Hulk up
until right now and again I'm just going
through and putting things in
chronological order so for the most part
it should just be one new video at the
bottom of the playlist all the time but
it may be that with something like this
I kind of have to jump back and inject a
little bit of info and modify its
placement in the playlist but I didn't
even if you guys are new here two
comments explained and you guys enjoy
this video make sure you hit the like
button make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the robb core we are
getting rings soon we are getting real
soon don't worry and um hopefully soon
anyway and leave a comment down below
let me know what you guys think about
the incredible home video so far because
you guys really seem to like them and I
love doing them like The Incredible Hulk
is amazing like I always felt like the
whole never got enough respect when it
came to comics and his stories are
pretty solid sometimes but anyway guys
we're gonna go ahead and wrap this up
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]